los arrow s is one of the busiest bus
stations in Bogota every day dozens of
Venezuelans gather here to eat talk or
simply enjoy each other's company most
came to Bogota on their own leaving
family and friends back home
in magoffin opening you have two little
boys twins that are 4 years old
just imagine staying in Venezuela would
have meant letting us all starve
I suffer from hypertension and it wasn't
easy to get my medication Mayella now
sells candy inside the so called
TransMilenio buses which you can jump on
and off with just a single ticket yes
i'm another venezuelan who came to this
country to try and move on i know this
is annoying for you because there are
lots of us here Mayella is trying to
sell enough of these chocolate bars to
pay for her boys birthday party back
home though she won't be able to be
there herself and she isn't the only one
selling chocolate Engelbert is 20 years
old and arrived in Colombia a month ago
he feels embarrassed but needs to sell
at least two boxes of chocolate a day to
make ends meet I worked for an entire
year to gather the money to come here I
was studying computer engineering but I
had to migrate because of the situation
I'm here trying to help my parents from
what I hear and I send them at least
30,000 Colombian pesos a week
that's about $10 in Venezuela a lot of
money but here in Colombia you can
barely feed a family for a day locals
working outside the official system are
finding it hard to share their customers
with hundreds of new competitors my
income is not the same anymore we used
to make 70 80 thousand now we barely
make 30 or 20 we have to find something
else the Colombian economy has struggled
over the last four years with oil prices
dropping on the international market
this has led to rising unemployment and
ever more people working outside the
system depending on how you look at it
about 50% of the Colombian labor market
is informal that is outside the official
sector and Venezuelans are coming in
with different types of informal
businesses especially on the streets and
with entertainment activities the new
jobs that don't require special
permission or bureaucratic processes
like in the financial sector or
commercial business no one knows exactly
how many of the Venezuelans here plan to
stay some say about a hundred thousand
into Colombia every month that could
mean over a million by the end of the
year and this means not only instability
for the unprepared Colombian economy but
also the threat of a major humanitarian
crisis